generally I don't like to talk about
celebrities too often because I don't
really care about celebrity culture that
being said I think when it comes to
certain instances I do like to see if
there's underlying problems or themes
that can be relevant to the general
something that we would work with yeah
so for example with this case of Amanda
Steele's if you aren't familiar she's a
black entertainer part of the cast of
insecure she's a stand-up comedian you
might have seen on HBO and recently as
well as the last couple years she's been
involved a lot of issues and a lot of
disputes with people online and in
person I've watched her in a few
interviews now and every time I've seen
her I felt like she exhibits a lot of
behavior that indicates to me that she
may be a narcissist recently she was
denied entering into a black Emmy party
and it turned into a big deal so I
decided do some research on Amanda I'm
gonna play some clips from her and I
just want you guys to look for
narcissistic behavior you know I told
Lisa I was like hey you know your
publicist like she's just like she's
just not being nice like she's just
nasty and I don't even need her to be
kind but just have a certain layer of
civility with me I don't want this to be
an easy interview I am ready to address
whatever well first of all are you still
on insecure what kind of dumbass
question is no we're not doing that but
I feel like I think it's interesting
that she demands civility and kindness
what everyone reports about her is that
she's the exact opposite I think I've
gotten in my own way by being more
honest than I needed to be in certain
situations this is not conceder
cockiness this is somebody who is really
sat here and looked at this I think some
people don't like me because I'm very
light-skinned I think some people don't
like me because I'm a woman with a very
strong point of view and an opinion I
think some people don't like me because
I may reflect something that they desire
this is the reason why people don't like
me is because you know I'm wonderful
I'm amazing and people don't like me for
that people don't like me because I'm a
total [ __ ] which stands for beat babe
in total control of herself that's why
they don't like me like I'm in control I
Jesus got the real no I'll grab the
wheel people don't like me because I'm
the captain of this shenanigans I know
I'm the captain now no no I'm the
captain anyways people don't like I
think some people don't like me for the
reasons that they don't like themselves
and I know that there are reasons you
don't like me that were handed down to
you in some situations by patriarchy I
mean by racism I mean by classism etc
you know you don't like me because I can
talk proper or something you know like
if that's a source of ire for you like
I'm like mad there's somebody put it in
you
something's wrong with y'all like you
guys were taught this I'm like no no so
you're just a dislikeable person and
there's some parts of me and Abba that
are very dislikeable sure look I eat
oatmeal with hot sauce dislikeable I
think if we look at like the hundred
percent of that there's probably about
5% of those situations where like yeah I
owe you an apology yeah you know you
know yeah you know what fine yeah I've
been bullied for being smart
I don't know how being unabashedly smart
has become such a villainous thing let
me say this if you have to say that
you're smart multiple times in an
interview you're not nearly as smart as
you think you hear thieves are thousand
bodies rich my touch is at a point where
I'm just smart enough to realize how
dumb I really am yup meaning I see the
chasm between me and people were truly
highly intelligent and I recognize how
difficult it is to stand with them in a
conversation about certain topics so I
tend to just listen in those scenarios
but I'm smart enough to know when
someone is full of [ __ ]
and that's the most frustrating thing
about that kind of curve is that dumb
people far overestimate their
intelligence intelligent people really
can't relate with a lot of dumb people
and people who are in the middle find
themselves frustrated because they
realize how much of a distance there are
between them and smart people and how
and they get frustrated at dumb people
for not realizing how dumb they actually
are and so I sit here and I listen to
you I don't like boo boo you're not
nearly as smart as you think you are
you're not you don't talk nearly as
proper as you think you do proper and
that arrogance and that kind of
egotistical aspect of you is what makes
people dislike you so much
more people here you the more they
actually get to see you and more of what
they've seen the more they decide if you
look at The Breakfast Club interviews
with her
the dislikes on those videos have grown
with each passing time and also because
people are really starting to see you
for who you are it's ironic that her
book is called small doses because it
seems like people can only handle her in
small doses it seemed insecure
all right that's just corny but I could
help myself
for years I don't think yeah we might
like that we even if other people speak
about me that way I would never repeat
that kind of stuff for kind of boast
about you also have a big head false
image projection narcissists tend to
project a false idolize image of
themselves to the world in order to hide
their inner sin security literally
people think that me being a critical
thinker is me being extra me being too
much but there were a lot of people who
used to say things like that about you
know Stokely Carmichael about you epe
about Martin Luther King like all they
stirring up trouble no no I am [ __ ]
scolder and Mully I'm a crusader like
I'm the green beret but I have become
the patron saint for difficult women boo
boo if you have to say it it ain't true
I'm a green beret
I'm the infantry and the Navy Jesus I'm
God I'm Mary
I'm Joseph the cook I'm a crusader do
you know what a crusade a crusader did
though yeah he [ __ ] slaughter and
murder people and Crusaders weren't good
people no that's me know my history if
you know anything about the multiple
Oh Leland they were terrible people and
I think it's very ironic that you call
yourself one of them because most people
think you're a terrible person in terms
of like am i a terrible person that's
absolutely ridiculous and absurd like
and if we're measuring that I'm like
well what kind of meat are y'all
measuring that on like so there's people
that we can acknowledge our 100%
terrible people are Kelly is a terrible
person
mm-hmm yes oh I'm so I'm or Kelly now
you know there's a spectrum and in the
category of terrible people yes there's
Hitler those are Kelly but there are
other terrible people who are not as bad
right yes like Jesse small a terrible
person did a terrible terrible thing
would I put him as him no course not and
I just want to point something out
Amanda loves to proclaim herself a
feminist fighting for women imagine if
men use that same behavior to downplay
whatever form of sexual assault they
engaged
oh you said I'm a rapist
Bill Cosby that's it countable for what
you did you know this kind of she always
loved to say how smart I am boom you got
a lot of logical inconsistencies you see
I know people to watch it's never like
okay Amanda said you know these are the
reasons but what do you think you did to
that young lady for her to feel that way
towards you I have no idea really I have
no idea what do you say something me I
think we're not even gonna acknowledge
that individual cuz he did that so they
get acknowledged no from your cast on
your TV show and he just said something
negative about you so it's very telling
to me that everyone that you've worked
with refuses to stand up for you but the
one that's a person who decided to speak
on the issue says something negative
about you know you just so you spent a
whole 30 minutes talking about how smart
and intelligent you are but you can't
detect why one person dislikes you no
wonder this person is unsuccessful in
relationship can you imagine having to
communicate with somebody who's that
lacking in self-awareness yeah
but know that I have looked out for him
okay why would you okay what happened
with him yeah we're not gonna talk about
him but know that I've been great with
that person so do you see how every
conversation she frames herself as the
victim she frames herself as infallible
never admits what she did wrong never
admits how she missed stuff but she's
always willing to say how she's done
good things you are somebody who loves
to be on this platform you claim to be a
crusader
you want to help people with your advice
but you also may not be in the best
place to come to counsel people when you
are in need of counseling yourself I
would never ever suggest anyone listen
to your relationship advice you know
there's this idea that's floating around
that if you got haters it means you're
doing something right sometimes when
people hate you it's just because you're
hateable you think Isis is out there
like a man shout out to all my haters we
bout to go jihad on that ass no Isis has
got justifiable haters the same way you
Amanda or a hateable person you know you
love to say oh I'm not for everybody
okay good that's what your Instagram
says but then you're surprised when
people who are not for you don't want to
be around you and you act shocked it's
because you're a narcissist and I just
make this video today because I want my
people at home to know what that
behavior looks like if you see it in
your dating partner run for the hills
because you will never be able to get
them to be accountable for the mistakes
that they make in your dynamic and you
need that from your partner that's it
for today's video we want to hear your
thoughts
do you guys know people were not to
stick how do you feel that manifests and
what are your thoughts in this hole
Amanda Steel saga stag him let us know
yo her name is seals looks like she'll
never get a kiss from a rose
[Music]
soon our cysts are also fond of using
guilt blame and victimhood
as manipulative devices that's when a
security guard approached me and was
like I'm sorry missus we have to ask you
to leave
and I was like ask me to leave what are
we talking about and he was like yeah
and I said find out who wants me to
leave so you found out who wanted me to
leave and he let me know and then three
other security guards approached and and
people think like Oh was a party like
why she's so stressed about a party I'm
stressed because I'm a black woman and
four men surrounded me to remove me from
somewhere that I belonged the security
guards are somehow threatening you you
literally were told to leave and then
you're like no no I want to find out
who's making me wanna leave the security
guy took the time to go find out who
wanted you gone and then they came back
and asked you to leave once again that's
very patient plenty superb you guys like
not to go get out now you know even pay
for your drinks unless they throw you
out like you jazz from Fresh Prince of
bel-air
I was then escorted out and the security
guard who had been kind the whole time
he said I'm sorry for doing that you
know but we have to do our jobs
this was hurt on by herself on the
podcast explaining what the situation
was for men surrounded me to remove me
from somewhere that I belonged you
didn't belong there they didn't want you
there they didn't want you there it's
not because it's a black Emmy party that
you belong there because you're black
because if the person organizing that
any party doesn't want you there boo boo
honey chicken cerita honey bun a bunch
with a slice a lot want a cherry on top
you do not belong there you know what
they say right don't go where you're
tolerated go where you're wanted yo we
need to wrap this video up because I
gotta go to the this KKK rally
[Music]
why would I go what will be your name
within the KKK Grandmaster Flash I'm
stressed because I know that another
woman has put me in this situation and
that stresses me out for a number of
reasons because I'm also stressed out
for her because I'm like damn what what
are you dealing with that would cause
you so much pain to put me into so much
[Music]
you literally turn this around and make
it sound like there's something in
bounced with her because she does not
want you at her party is you you see the
level of narcissism or they pass off us
looking sympathetic but really they're
just arrogant as hell damn I'm praying
for Monique I want Monique to find in
healing she needs she's been talking
about the same things in the same people
for the last 15 years I'm new to the
conversation but the Oprah the Tyler
Perry the Lee Daniels everybody else is
always the problem and even if those
people did her wrong she got to let that
hurt go because it's not good for her
mental health interesting that you have
that opinion about Monique Charlemagne
but you don't have that same opinion
about Amanda